jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quel est le lieu idéal pour une étreinte
ali avait tout simplement vous préférez
draguer ou faire draguer me faire
draguer ah bon on peut être chaîne de
garde voyez vous préférez vous préféré
larguer ou faire larguer me faire
larguer ça m'est jamais arrivé et largué
je peux pas le faire c'est la vie qui
s'en charge mais c'est ce que je sais
pas faire mais vous pouvez faire
embrasser vous faire embrasser embrassez
vous préférez caresser vous faire
caresser les faire car et c'est là on a
tout le mode d'emploi du lieu où vous
seriez incapable de faire l'amour la
fourrière
si vous avez besoin d'aimer pour faire
l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour aimer
de faire l'amour pour aimer peut pas
baiser comme ça vraiment pas fier je
veux m'aimer je tombe amoureuse après ça
si c'est à peu près bien fait comme il
faut est ce que vous préférez un mec qui
baisent bien mais qu est infidèle ou un
mec qui baisent mal mais les fidèles qui
baissent bien qu'un fidèle
ouais parce qu'on peut toujours corriger
le tir pour certaines choses et pas pour
d'autres actes pas de podium est pour
toi dans le complet ce que vous vous
êtes partisan dit partisan à tisanes
partisane que faisait qu est ce que vous
êtes partisan de rien savoir où tout se
dire c'est la question la plus
importante ça sera la seule question qui
intéresse des millions de gens est ce
que je vais bien fait rien savoir
et puis joly est-ce que vous avez des
fantasmes non encore réalisé ouais
combien et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu